il est partout
[Musique]
mais on passe sans le voir
pourtant il est là depuis toujours
[Musique]
le bidon
rien de plus capverdien qu'un bidon
on devrait même le mettre sur le drapeau
national
pour comprendre le pays
il faut suivre la route du bidon
[Musique]
en plastique en métal en tir ou en
morceaux toujours transporté souvent
transformé
il raconte une journée dans la vie des
cavernes
[Musique]
ce matin Francisco est descendu au port
de Mindelo
[Musique]
un cargo vient d'arriver de France
dans ce hangar des bidons envoyés par la
diaspora ils viennent de Paris Boston ou
Lisbonne
à l'intérieur de la nourriture des
vêtements des jouets autant de cadeaux
qu'on peut rarement s'offrir dans
l'archipel
je cherche mon nom
il doit bien être écrit quelque part
[Musique]
il faut que je le trouve
sinon je partirai d'ici trop triste
il se ressemblent tous tous tous sont
remplis de la vie des autres
[Musique]
deux ans que Francisco n'en avait pas
reçu un pour lui
je n'arrive pas à mettre des mots
très spécial
mes frères mes sœurs sont tous à
l'étranger immigrés et ils se sont punis
pour m'envoyer un bidon
ça me touche vraiment beaucoup
j'ai hâte de l'ouvrir
tout a commencé deux mois plus tôt très
loin du Cap-Vert
à Asnières en région parisienne
[Musique]
depuis 25 ans nana la sœur aînée de
Francisco a fait sa vie ici en France
il se retrouve sans travail en ce moment
en ce qui est ce qui part là ça va
l'aider pendant un petit moment
la fille de Nana participe elle pense à
sa jeune cousine
donc je sais que quand j'étais petite
c'était très difficile
donc
maintenant j'ai le moyen de je peux
envoyer des petites choses et j'envoie
j'envoie ton cœur
tant que je respire j'envoie voilà
c'est fou tout ce qui peut tenir dans un
bidon des provisions des vêtements
mais aussi tout ce qui ne peut pas se
dire
entre ceux qui sont partis et ceux qui
sont restés
inconnu de chat de ce que tu as envoyé
ta tante nana
il doit y avoir de la nourriture dedans
j'espère que ma sœur a mis de la
nourriture
je suis sûr qu'on ne pourrait jamais les
acheter ici même en travaillant toute
une vie
dans la vie Francisco n'a pas grand
chose
mais il a demandé à sa sœur de ne pas
oublier ses voisines
et il les a invités à la cérémonie
d'ouverture
[Musique]
une surprise toujours une surprise c'est
pas tous les jours qu'on voit ce genre
de truc dans notre quartier
nous nous n'avons rien on s'unit et on
se soutient mutuellement
ce soir tout aura été distribué le bidon
sera vide
[Musique]
mais il n'a pas fini sa route
au Cap Vert le bidon a plusieurs vies
[Musique]
et certains en font un business
c'est le plus grand marché du Cap-Vert à
Praia la capitale
[Musique]
on vend de tout et donc des bidons
d'occasion
donne-nous deux bidons c'est combien
et 11 euros mais je vous le fais pour
neuf
sur le marché on les surnomme les rastes
des bidons
Martello prend celui-là voici Dino et
Martello
nous on évite d'acheter ceux qui sont
cabossés on choisit ceux qui sont bien
lourds
il faut qu'il soit lourd et robuste
aussi ne doit pas être trop léger les
bidons les plus lourds sont meilleurs à
travailler donc on fait très attention
quand on les choisit
[Musique]
les deux amis vont faire des miracles
avec ses bidons
mais d'abord il y a 45 minutes de trajet
jusqu'à leur atelier
un jeu d'enfant
au presque
je préfère rouler les bidons avec une
seule main c'est plus facile pour moi
je trouve que c'est plus rapide aussi
Martello lui il a besoin des deux mains
il est plus habitué comme ça enfin c'est
surtout qu'il y arrive pas avec une main
voici leur atelier enfin leur bout de
trottoir
[Musique]
la commande du jour une petite pelle à
poussière
première étape il faut détruire le bidon
pour qu'il renaisse en plaques de métal
si tu travailles sans prendre les
mesures ça n'aura pas la forme d'une
pelle pour que ça ait la forme d'une
pelle il faut prendre la largeur dont tu
as besoin
c'est une question de précision on doit
tout couper de façon très précise pour
bien la fabriquer et ensuite bien vendre
pour le corps de la pelle ce petit
rectangle de métal suffira
[Musique]
les deux bricoleurs prennent ensuite un
bout du cerclage c'est un eau métallique
qui permet le bidon pour fabriquer le
manche
[Musique]
Martello et Dino fabriquent aussi leur
propre rivet 2 cm de tige écrasé au
marteau
ça y est
[Musique]
c'est de voir cette pelle terminée je me
sens fier
je suis content d'avoir bien travaillé
d'avoir fait un travail digne un travail
sérieux
c'est ça ma fierté
celle-ci c'est une poêle qui l'a fait il
y a longtemps elle est encore en super
état
et je crois qu'elle tiendra la route
pendant un moment
on l'utilise pour faire des poulailler
[Musique]
ou Main d'Or
en OspA imaginer ce qu'il ferait avec de
bons outils un établi ou même de
l'électricité
j'aimerais être le maître du bidon
vraiment être le meilleur dans ce
domaine
[Musique]
le maître des bidons existe
il vit sur l'île de ça en vicène
c'est Mikao
il pense bidon il vit bidon
le bidon en fait c'est chez lui
dans cette maison on aime dans le
désordre le benfic à Lisbonne
Jésus-Christ les chats
et un certain acteur américain
d'ailleurs le petit dernier a été appelé
Leonardo
voici ma maison ça c'est le salon ici
c'est la cuisine ça c'est du bidon ici
c'est du bidon tout est en bidon ici
aussi tout est construit avec du bidon
je suis très content de vous présenter
ma maison j'en suis vraiment très fier
[Musique]
une maison simple mais coquettes
son seul défaut
elle est un peu petite
ça c'est le lit où nous dormons ma femme
et moi
il y a un matelas et là un autre matelas
cela on les met par terre c'est pour les
enfants ils dorment dans le salon
mais ça ne va pas durer
Mikao veut ajouter une nouvelle chambre
c'est justement son métier amicaux
construire il construit en dur et vit en
bidon
aujourd'hui après le travail ces
camarades de chantier vont lui donner un
coup de main pour son extension
voici la matière première
salut Georges ça va bien ouais
tranquille
25 bidons valeur 150 euros vas-y je le
prends donne-le
[Musique]
si tu fais comme ça il sera tout denté
regarde fais plutôt dans ce sens là
travailler le bidon c'est vraiment
quelque chose que j'aime faire j'adore
les prendre ils sont tout rond au début
et je les transforme en tôle toute plate
toute lisse comme ça c'est vraiment beau
je vais te dépasser goulicha ouais ouais
c'est ça
retour chez Mikao dans la ville haute
les plaques sont tranchantes comme des
rasoirs
[Musique]
c'est un peu dangereux il faut faire
attention pour ne pas blesser quelqu'un
[Musique]
c'est la catastrophe
pose-le il y a vraiment trop de vent là
[Musique]
au travail
pour gagner des mètres carrés Mikao a vu
grand une maisonnette indépendante
plutôt qu'une chambre en enfilade
[Musique]
attends attends
son grand fils de 18 ans
c'est important d'avoir une maison à moi
ça veut dire que je suis en train de
devenir vraiment un adulte le grand-père
est là aussi
ça va le faire ça va le faire comme ça
dans le quartier il fait autorité
l'invention des maisons en bidon c'est
un truc récent ça date des années 70 à
peu près
[Musique]
pour construire une maison en bidon il
faut quand même s'y connaître
le mécano commence
en quelques heures la maisonnette sort
de terre
[Musique]
sans permis de construire mais avec une
situation idéale sur les hauteurs
par ici
les riches ils veulent toujours ce qu'il
y a de meilleur
il le veulent pour eux tout seul mais
nous aussi on y a droit
[Musique]
avec le bidon tout est sur mesure
nous on a la plus belle vue de Mindelo
et je l'adore
[Musique]
je fais cette fenêtre pour mon fils pour
qu'il puisse regarder cette vue je la
fais avec mon cœur cette fenêtre il sera
content d'être là
[Musique]
ce soir il y a une maison de plus dans
le quartier
et ne dites pas à Mikao que c'est un
bidonville
les maisons en bidon elles sont vraiment
belles et nous on n'est pas comme ça ça
nous donne le cœur joyeux c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui nous appartient pour
moi il n'y a aucune différence avec une
maison en béton
allez kiki tu nous fais un discours non
non arrêtez un discours
un discours allez dis quelque chose lève
la tête
je suis vraiment content d'avoir cette
chambre ça faisait longtemps que je
voulais avoir mon propre espace alors je
remercie tous les amis de ce qu'ils ont
fait pour moi et ton père tu lui dis
quoi alors allez un bisou merci
c'est ici que s'arrête la route du bidon
après avoir traversé les océans il ne
pouvait pas rêver mieux
finir en maison
c'est maintenant au fils de Mikao de lui
dire
un grand merci
[Musique]